okay we have some time for discussion
and I want to thank the speakers for
keeping well within the time limits I
thought that there was some really
interesting overarching arguments that
came through all of the four papers and
I was particularly struck by the way
that alicia's was setting up the panel
in a sense by talking about the
aspirations of anonymity as opposed to
the compulsions towards Dalit identity
and I think each of the speaker's was in
his own way trying to engage with this
you know fundamental paradox of the the
search for the dissolution of Dalit
identity but that yet at the same time
Dalit identity keeps resurfacing as both
what retains the caste structure in
these various religions and at the same
time I think in Rajas very interesting
comment about how Dalit the Dalit is
seen to also save Sikhism from virtually
imploding and becoming yet another caste
based religion and so it's this tension
between the aspiration to anonymity and
the salvaging of of the Dalit identity
which seems in some respects to also
shape each of these different religions
Sikhism Islam and Christianity and so I
thought that you know the the overall
point that lucious was making about how
Ambedkar's conversion project was in a
sense intended to democratize religion
and make religion accessible to all and
not just you know from the viewpoint of
the physical structures of religion like
temple or Church or so forth but to also
make religion capacious enough to in
fact
subsume faith under a moral convictions
I think this is a point that I was made
in a lucious's talk so I wondered if
anyone one might just want to make a
quick comment you know in relationship
to the other papers in a sentence or two
Raj before we just throw this up open to
discussion i I do found lucious's paper
and the idea of an aspiration on
anonymity you know I think that is
process that precisely right and I don't
have a comment only because I think you
pretty much hit upon it exactly and said
it you know quite precisely but I
certainly agree
oh and it's okay I'm modeling nitrogen
thank you so much for a wonderfully rich
a panel I just wanted to follow up with
Gary's comment the notion of anonymity
and identity seems to me that there are
two more terms that could usefully move
that ahead and I think it's already been
done in some of the other things that he
said one is about marked and unmarked
bodies and the way in which anonymity
the concept that datura asking us to
think about has something to do with not
with self-identification but with
society not identifying us so it seems
to be coming from outside of the self
unless I'm completely missing the point
and in that sense the two the two papers
by Raj Kumar and Masucci are absolutely
fascinating because of the way in which
the only way it seems for Dalits within
the two religions to actually get
anonymity is by making their at the
littleness into the sick or the Muslim
identity so in between the cast and the
nation lies this realm of this religion
and I just wanted anybody to maybe say
something on thank solutions Rajan
Masood Lucius
yes tell it's empirical studies are
finding their words now two theories and
one two questions for each panel like
one of the questions I'll be direct
Allah says when Ambedkar tried to make
Buddhism a universal religion by putting
his theory in Buddha and Amma
the it's between the Democratic thing I
fundamental kind of a thing which is
happening among Buddhism also the way
I'm Beatrice but then demise banned in
Sri Lankan
monastery's and you know i'm certain i
that moves also all over the buddhists
on this thing and at the same time an
effort is made to her embrace luck you
know temperature to accept buddhism in
the form of engaged Buddhism by there's
certain action activities like how do we
address this paradoxical situation first
thing and to Raj when we are talking
about Sikhism yes then let's they
protected the religion but you know how
how this added um there a moment Punjab
negotiated with this religion and in a
way like which influenced most that I
know how it didn't graduate it with the
movement as well as the religion what is
it discourse going on and Masood the
when come into contemporary minority
reservations issue I think you missed it
because paucity of time I could get it
but when religion itself you know you
know we could be unclear now it's not
equal in the beginning from the
beginning itself but the Dalits who
migrated who conversed embraced into
Islam since century centuries the power
to ratio is also more among Dalit
Muslims but there is a when the Muslims
Dalits Muslims are fighting for the
reservations but there is an equal
opposition from the Islamic forces
against it in Hyderabad in Andhra we
could see that you know how you relate
to this issue in your think
actually I was overtaken by the
presentation by mr. lucious
maybe he's given little more time to
talk about identity and anonymity but
before that I would just make a you know
a small observation you made a statement
saying that you need to know how the
oppressors mind work and you know how
plans are you know how the conspiracy
takes place therefore you can find out
ways you know to save people literally
the Dalits but I find the other way for
example there is a crime scene and you
reach there there are evidences
everywhere because without evidences
crimes are not committed so you can
always take the thread from there and
find out and the culprit so what I'm
trying to say is because too much
emphasis on theories and theorizing
sometimes need not necessarily lead to
solutions so we can always find the
evidences and from there also we can
lead take some cues and you can solve
the issues I think we can just ask for
the responses because there are very
substantial questions I was so far you
see most of the time we have been
engaged in collecting evidences you know
men constitutional promised actual
performance but when we collect counter
evidences after 50 percent your strategy
has to change you know you you keep on
by finding for example take a corruption
so on so it's corrupt so on
is corrupt people Santa's corrupt 60% is
corrupt 70% then he doesn't anymore mean
anything
one was to count men they say why is it
some people are not corrupt you see that
the it's purely a methodological
question I'm asking you are presuming
bona fide a very good and okay the plan
performance the lower-level officials
are not performing things etc etcetera
and so on and so forth but then we worse
you are overwhelmed and then you start
thinking there is something else at play
here you see that is where you know you
find that you are allowed to survive it
is a miracle one should be grateful so
from that strategy you know you will
have to see how things work then you
will be little more you know better - is
it so many people what'd he say
yesterday no it was very beautiful you
have been saying in my leak I come from
the tribal area some 20 years I have
been there rayar I know I know this but
the actuality is a hundred times worse
than this what we can find out through
our research is nothing compared to what
actually is taking place
so actually I think you actually said I
think the whole planning process starts
from the other way round my niece has
come from some Hume pipes technology
from United States of America so let us
start a Humes
public limited company and the matter a
current power this is the way the whole
process is the structural functionalism
for those who studied sociology you know
as stocked up and functions increased
structures also increase no other way
around
in many of our situations that is why
that is why I mean now one has to reread
on to approach the empirical facts as a
sort of tabula rasa not mean empty mind
and so on
you know the under most of the of most
of the
ordinary people who are normal
experiences they know this they may not
be able to tell you they may not get
intimidated but they know they are not
quietly they're very sort of hard-nosed
to sort of people as for theory my own
engagement is a 2d mythologized this
theory I mean that formerly Vedas was
knowledge now knowledge is the Vedas I
don't believe in that
okay so it is it is a it is generalized
statement and you have because what
happens is it is in the generalized
realm of theory that power is loaded
power is loaded the moment you are
concentrating on the trees you miss the
forest forest is being conducted here
independent of the amount of trees that
are planted here
um can I also have large because he - so
this question of you see added her
moment and the relationship with Sikhism
and so on I think in the late last
quarter of the 19th century there was
quite kind of competition among the
established religions to win over you
see that its arias emerges Arya samajis
was doing at UC with quite an Elan and
they should the movement was quite
anyway you see successful in the
beggining and sinks abides were also
trying to do the same also I think it
was a question of you see representative
politics that numbers game of numbers
was at play and then you have also you
see Muslims also playing the same game
what is very interesting about others
that will be moving moment is that it
was the autonomous religious movement
initiated by one of the revolutionaries
who was caught in California then he was
in Philippines and then he had gone back
who was from the chibok community was
himself for the death and he said that
our religion we did a we don't belong to
any
other established religion our religion
is the oldest because indigenous people
had their own religion so he had a
26-point program where which was based
on rationality I think quite a lot was
taken also from Buddhism and it's very
strange that you see when it became such
a successful mobilization of that it's
often job that within five years in 1931
census for lacan seventy four hundred
seventy thousand you see people enlisted
as other means and when this option was
open and this was very powerful
autonomous religious movements the earth
movements but when computer was trying
to find out the alternatives for the
Dalits of India and I think he had this
example before him that actually there
was also simultaneously ah-ah-ah-ah
diandra you see movement and it could
have been the best kind of option but I
don't understand why I'm being cut did
not think of following you see Arthur a
moment rather then you see he was trying
to find out Sikhism because that was
there are all the time 1930 is five or
thirty six and then he was experimenting
with that so so much so that Adi thermy
many a six because those who knew that
there was equally you see caste has
afflicted Sikhism as well they have
already declared themselves you see are
either mean independent of Sikhism as
the metaphor is a vision among Muslims
the lip OBC an upper caste matter now
Prakash Muslims not against from now
they have against of clemente of OBC
Muslim Messiah rokosz was named from
beginning we can see that day with
nausea Sultana made our local Muslims
say yahood hungry he's the common
general and wash luckily made his corner
of the leaf convert a Muslim
Khan and Mallika food and moment table
when he gives so many positions do
indigenous Muslims they were attacked by
African Muslims they ever against from
beginning not now I know many mentions
all ovations who led by Muslim cosmos
names even your answer for this lesson
is omnia have issued a fatwa that means
say Islamic rule and 3062 mother says
Islamic education centres signed their
decision on the caste based is the Haram
but now we can see echo in the Bihar
there is a cost is the Malik he's not
claiming only that either say yeah but
mom says earnest based say yet they have
two three PhDs they have many books so
that through that they are say yes but
after now there is a sham there are a
stimulation on the poverty line but they
are not getting that position on the
party line they now declared themselves
that is the talia i oppressor and it is
a government give reservation see
anything unhappiness Shack cast the name
is a Bihar now they are getting Iran to
take a listen new shake means they are
not shake shake their new shake many
this is a historically there are against
a document of OBC and the Muslims not a
new thing Chris Queen so many of us are
familiar with the narrative of Baker's
investigation of the choices available
to him after yellow declaration in 1936
and in fact the basic teachings of all
these religions are universal and
emancipatory and anti caste if you will
so why did he choose Buddhism because in
fact I think the panel shows that each
of those who is a viable option well
accepted each of them was attested by
practicing communities in India at the
time except for Buddhism except for the
Tibetan refugees and perhaps some
Brahmin practitioners of the
my bode society or something like that I
would suggest perhaps that Buddhism was
a blank slate on which he could import
the modernity and rationality which
you've all referred and to create a an
emancipatory practice or concept that
was necessary for his community at the
time and while it was a summing up of
much that when before it was a vast the
creative act on on his part and his
writings in this respect are somewhat
mystifying to practicing Buddhist
communities in other part of the world
because it's a new Buddhism it's a novel
Yana so my question for the panel is
perhaps this was a strategy but a very
timely one for him and his people
good morning it's nice to be here this
morning my name is Madan my question
another comment is for mr. hands I was I
was born and raised in rural Punjab so I
know Sikhism and as far as my memory
goes back in those time the Dalits have
worked as servants for their sick
landlords who was predominantly six I
mean as I said so they used to live for
the livelihood morning on all the entire
family will work for these landlords and
the evening they will get something to
eat for the living and during that time
they they give their names they attach
Singh after the last name so in other
terms okay I'm sorry you can yeah my
question is that in spite of all those
you know giving names but the social
status was unchanged they stay in their
own thing that have their own place of
worships they have their own everything
the same so my question is when you were
so much a Dallas was so much sort of
kept separate and there in the social
forum how they could embrace that
religion
I'm gonna get Val and George on Val
Daniel Columbia University I took your
point very well about my ethical choice
of Buddhism being tabula rasa cleans
Kate under the circumstances for
instance it would be because it because
we in Sri Lankan Buddhism for instance
caste is their hierarchy is there quite
clearly but I want to ask the panelists
I mean this very interesting idea that
Dalits forms of Sikhism or Dalits
practices of in Islam or presence in
Islam itself sort of a challenge to the
hierarchy in hierarchies in tendencies
that would otherwise go on unchecked the
Christians in in in India of course
Tristian the Canes are availa into a
with hierarchy on their side as it was
being Western colonial factor coming in
on who Indian society I was also very
moved by Nate's needs paper
Pentecostalism at this level
I know Indian Christianity at the other
churches higher churches are very
hierarchies car-sized and so on almost
it's become accepted but this at this
time the Buddhism seems to have being a
good choice but also it just it is it's
passivity of pacifism and passivity is
what didn't make it has made made it as
politically viable as it could have been
but here is to me it seems like
Pentecostalism is also in
at a time when the temp temperament and
sentiments are different in in the world
we're also in the in the country and it
seems to be too though all the
presentations it seems to be the most
successful exercised rationality if I'm
if I read it correctly and my question
is is this a harbinger of kind of spread
of a certain kind of Christianity
especially among that its how how is
this spreading idea is this spreading
elsewhere among that is Pentecostalism
as an as not traditional Christianity
but another form of it's an empirical
question now I it is spreading it is
quite vibrant at the same time I don't
want to you know predict the future
there are certain inherent limitations
to it that I suspect it will it won't
sort of take over one is that it's
mainly women who are attracted to it
within Islam and within the women it's
the women who are the most worse off and
there's one main reason other people
don't turn to Pentecostalism is it's
just too hard it's too hard to be
Pentecostal it demands too much you pray
too much so Christ is seen as a God of
last resort and pen is not fun I mean
there's a certain fun in going to church
for three hours but let me tell you it
can get very old and so the burdens of
being a Pentecostal are it so at once
it's very vibrant it's very powerful but
people won't do it unless they tried
praying all the other gods it doesn't
work you know and then they'll turn to
to Christ then we have
yeah it's intense very good observation
one thing that why guru Govind Singh had
chosen to give you see one singles
surname or say last name to all the sex
was also it was a revolt against the
till then only rod booze or kshatriyas
could use the sub name single and in
order to eliminate these caste
distinctions Guru Gobind Singh said that
all the six now would be henceforth
would be known as Singh's so that you
see even then it's would have known as
sings or be upper caste would also be
known as sings but what is interesting
in this is that the way the Dalits or
even the sick the lists have been
excluded from the land land the use of
lands and I think that was done with the
rise of the juts as a political power at
the end of the 18th century and that
culminated you see in the Ranjit Singh's
rule of nearly 50 years and then juts
became the sole owners of the land so
much so that the colonial power of the
colonial rule you see the British as
passed a act called land alienation act
in 1900 that whereby they had already I
didn't identified that land could only
be owned by the agricultural communities
even though the Denis had been
agriculturists they were not included in
that as agriculturist and hence all
together you see denied the right to own
the land along with other communities
and quite paradoxically while the Dalits
constitute 30 percent or 33 percent of
the total population of Punjab they
owned only two point four five four
percent which is the lowest I think a
bit compared to any other state they
while their proportion of the number
numerical strength is the
highest as compared to any other part of
India their share in the land is the
lowest so there's I think my question is
to need I think it's a fascinating
research that he's done and he's made
some important observations thank you
for that but made my question is in your
research did you find that to me it
sounded like you know Pentecostalism is
a more convenient religion for the poor
women or poor elite women to embrace
because you know they don't have to
worry about wearing joelle so being that
you know status symbol but did you find
in your research that once they moved up
a certain economic you know sudden wrong
in the economic ladder did they tend to
move into other churches or did they
tend to remain within that I'm not sure
if you've been able to find that out or
not that's a good question um it also
empirically the answer is I don't know
because they weren't moving up so it did
improve their status visa vie the men in
Islam and visit visibly their troubled
relations with men and other women but
but they weren't it wasn't a road to
success so I could only speculate
speculation is what we should all do
outside over a cup of tea coffee thank
you to all the panelists thank you for
coming